[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander rose and the
executive director at the long now
foundation I wanted to tell you all a
little bit about what's coming up at the
interval so the interval is the new
space that long now just opened a month
ago Sunday and we are we've started a
lecture series there as well it's mostly
it's always on Tuesday nights and we've
had about six events now and all been
sold out and really lovely the next one
is actually very long now related it's
going to be about the Rosetta project
and the future of languages and its
co-presented with the global lives
project - and we've worked with before
as well so it'll be about endangered
languages the future of language and
that's on July 22nd I believe which is a
Tuesday and I think there's still a few
tickets left for that also we have
become a really lovely co-working space
it's fairly quiet during the day we have
good Wi-Fi so come on down and then the
bar gets quite Lively at night and for
members
I want you all I know how many of you
are members here tonight look at that
nice almost all of you thank you so
members get 10% off during the day to
say you're a member
hopefully you'll have your card with you
your stainless steel card and then
Monday nights you get 10% off all
evening as well so please come on by and
mention that you're a member and the
last thing I'll do is introduce the long
short for this evening
this is one that we've been kind of
itching to do for quite a while but we
we needed a speaker who had a good
enough sense of humor to to do it but
it's basically it's a future history of
an archaeology and I think you'll all
enjoy it good night it's astounding to
realize that it's been over
1,000 years since the Beatles walked the
earth first-hand records are certainly
scarce there's a lot that we don't know
about the Beatles but we do know that
these four young men John Lennon Paul
McKenna Z Greg Hutchinson and Scottie
Pippen were some of the finest musicians
that have ever existed
The Beatles rose to prominence when they
traveled from their native Lynne Burton
to America to perform at ed Sullivan's
annual Woodstock Festival Americans were
shocked I mean at this time the
overwhelming style of music was opera
nobody no one had ever heard of any
piece of music that was less than three
hours long The Beatles changed all that
and they were so prolific you know they
they had so many hit songs paperback
writer ticket to run wipeout don't stop
believin parents just don't understand
Jimmy crack corn Battle Hymn of the
Republic and what's truly amazing is
that they wrote all of these songs with
only the notes A through G musical
notation had not yet been expanded to be
their music dominated the charts even
with competition from such rivals as
Michael Jackson Louie Armstrong and
Ernest Hemingway it seemed there was
nothing the Beatles couldn't accomplish
1965 Shea Stadium the Beatles win the
Superbowl
twenty one to seven against the Giants
it was an immense event in the history
of athletics and it did quite a bit to
raise the nation's spirits after the
assassination of President Nixon L for a
while they acted in the television
series was called I Love Lucy the
prosthetics and makeup on the show was
just incredible you couldn't tell it was
them they invented the thumbs up it's a
gesture you don't see much anymore but
people would do this to each other and
the Beatles were the first to do it and
they were pioneers even in animation
Paul McKenzie just pin to paper just
noodling around and next thing you know
we have Mickey Mouse
perhaps the Beatles greatest
accomplishment came with the release of
their groundbreaking album Sargent Pet
Sounds and the spiders from Asia
sadly no copies of this album remain
they were all fed to Emperor gorlok in
26:52 however I've taken it upon myself
to form one of the finest meat ology
teams in the world
we have reconstructed ancient sheet
music in the hopes of determining what
this album might have sounded like these
are our findings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
soon after the album's release rumors
began to circulate that the Beatles
would break up they of course did not
and for decades they continued to grow
in popularity and size adding new
members each year today their influence
can be seen everywhere from the species
of insect that was named after them to
the children who make wishes on their
laps each beat --mess you know as we sit
here and talk about the Beatles one
thing is perfectly clear the Beatles
music will live forever in the hearts of
those who had their hearts frozen while
the Beatles are still alive
join us next week as we profile Orson
Welles the filmmaker behind the scathing
Vietnam War critique Dracula dead and
loving it
[Applause]
it's a bar of 10,000 years by the way
that the interval thing sort of in
keeping with this actually I am a Stuart
brand from the long now foundation the
great thing about museums we've had the
several speakers from museums too from
the Smithsonian and part of the art of
museums in the last couple decades has
been they've learned to use the objects
that they've collected and have all the
lore on and now they're telling stories
with those objects and I suppose the
best example of a book of that as Neal
McGregor's history of the world in 100
objects which you can get in the lobby
speaker tonight turned that upside down
suppose you start with a story and then
work out with the right object to put in
the museum is please welcome Adrienne
Han thank you so why write a history of
the 21st century today's day is a July
16th 2082 there's still 18 years until
the end of the 21st century and that may
seem a little foolhardy fur I'm a human
like me to try and analyze all the data
we have at our disposal after all we're
a wash with information from every
corner of the system covering every
second of the century a thousand
detailed histories of any subject you
care about can be generated the snap of
a finger
but I believe that as our century comes
to a close we should just look at the
big picture we should also look at the
small details the scale on which human
lives are lived because this has been an
extraordinary chapt an extraordinary
century in the story of humanity every
century is extraordinary of course some
maybe the bloodiest some may encapsulate
important evolutions in science or
religion or philosophy the 21st century
is a little different it represents the
first time in our history where we've
had the truly question what it means to
be human
it's not just a theoretical concern it's
a pressing practical concern and so
that's what I want to share with you
tonight out of the hundred objects that
I've detailed in this history I've
chosen six stories which I think
represent some of the best and some of
the worst that humanity has accomplished
this century spanning war science
artificial intelligence and inequality
so the first object I'd like to start
with is from 2019 the locked simulation
interrogation hostile virtual reality
simulations have to rank among some of
the worst nightmares we've invented in
this century today we have strict laws
about the use of lot Sims laws are baked
into hardware and that are enforced by
severe punishments locked Sims have very
few legitimate uses anymore other than
specialized therapy but unfortunately
they do have plenty of illegitimate
users with interrogation being the most
prominent the first use of locked
simulation interrogations dates back to
2019 following a series of five bombings
in North Carolina
FBI agents detained the subject who they
think aided the terrorists this suspect
was not responsive to the legal
interrogation techniques of the time and
with physical techniques such as
waterboarding prohibited by Congress in
2018 the FBI decided to test out a new
experimental procedure so the suspect
was fitted with a set of virtual reality
goggles along with a galvanic vestibular
stimulator to artificially alter their
sense of balance this system was powered
by the FBI's computing cloud to provide
a highly immersive and highly responsive
simulated environment however the FBI
also added another thing to the mix
because what I've described is a set up
there any rich person at the time could
afford they also added a portable brain
scanner to this setup which means that
they could closely monitor the subject
subjects reaction to a simulation of
their suppose of meeting with the
Bombers any strong emotional reaction to
the phrase of a place or a face would
make the next iteration of the
simulation focus and elaborate on those
specific elements uncooperative behavior
was swiftly punished by fear inducing
simulations which themselves were
refined based on the subjects brain
scans and so they were able to narrow in
on the truth so to speak of what
actually happened and during those
encounters and so over the course of
eight minutes simulations 572 of them
the FBI determined that likely locations
and identities for three of the Bombers
ultimately this information allowed them
to prevent as planned six bombing in
Charlotte in a much publicized press
conference following the arrests the FBI
credited the new suppose a non-invasive
zero contact questioning techniques of
saving thousands of lives as a result it
wasn't surprising that security service
was all around the world all around the
country were given carte blanche to use
adaptive VR interrogation of course they
didn't realize that the system wasn't
quite as reliable as it was made
to be had turned out through the North
Carolina case was more of a happy
accident than anything else too often in
adaptive VR simulations the users just
generated nonsense information still
over the next 15 years
adaptive VR interrogation became a
standard part of law enforcement
agencies toolkits at first it was used
just to investigate major terrorist
threats but as often happens with these
things the technology became easier and
cheaper to use and ended up trickling
down to more minor criminal cases the
successes were publicized and the
failures were quickly covered up
resulting in an almost perfect public
image but the severe and the permanent
psychological damage caused by some
adaptive VR interrogations also became
clear over those 15 years even with the
best will in the world many security
services were not able to prevent
innocent suspects from being mentally
scarred by days of locked sim
interrogations many suspects developed a
lifelong aversion for the people and the
places that they encountered in these
simulations tearing apart friendships
and families ultimately there were three
flaws with adaptive VR interrogation the
first was of the crude brain scanning
technology of the time was just not very
good it's often placed far too much
weight on subjects emotional responses
to completely irrelevant people or
places in the simulations secondly as
the Mossad and other security services
demonstrated on numerous occasions
trained agents could withstand hundreds
of simulations by conjuring up vivid and
consistent internal mental world's
thirdly and finally adaptive VR
interrogation was only as good as a
people and the data that would link to
it in other words there was always human
error thankfully the use of adaptive VR
interrogation was ruled unconstitutional
by the Supreme Court in 2033
a violation of the Eighth Amendment
against the use of cruel and unusual
punishments there's a landmark case
defining the use of brain scanning
technologies for law enforcement but it
was not the last and that brings me on
to the second object which is really
more about an event a movement than a
specific object so this is from 2030 for
the greatest of packages income in the
smallest places of changes can come in
the smallest of packages and this
package is one of millions manufactured
by the Christian consummation movements
and this is really no larger than my
thumb inside you'd see a little tiny
eyedropper and 18 pills and if I use
these eye drops and I swallowed the
pills and I enrolled in their perfectly
harmless induction course of targeted
viruses and transcranial magnetic
stimulation which I can assure you I am
NOT going to do then over the next few
months my personality and my temperament
would be gradually transformed my
aggressive tendencies would be lowered
I read early form strong trusting
friendships with the people I met during
this imprinting period which invariably
would be other members of the CCM and
also according to the CCM are become
more empathetic more generous less
desiring her fleeting individual mundane
pleasures some might say if they didn't
like me that this would be an
improvement on my personality that I've
become more serene and less vulnerable
to temptation others would say that my
individuality had been eroded by an
insidious form of desire modification
but everyone would probably agree that I
had actually changed so from the 30s in
the 2030s the twenty 70s over 20
million Americans joined the Christian
consumation movement and while it's
explosion and growth has slowed down
considerably in recent decades the CCMS
rise to become one of the largest
denominations of American Christianity
that presented a dramatic period of
really religious revival a fourth and
Great Awakening but if we want to
understand the origins of the
consummation movement we need to look at
the society in which they grew by the
early 2030s
mass automation and globalization had
permanently raised the US unemployment
rate to more than 25 percent with
underemployment more than doubling that
number some US states have introduced
enhanced social security and a basic
minimum income and that had taken the
financial sting for some people out of
this economic shift but money alone
couldn't replace the sense of meaning or
direction that many people had once
derived from work and all could at
address a fragmentation of thousands of
physical communities based around work
the co-founder of the Christian
consumation movement dr. Sarah alderman
she aimed to fill that gap dr. alderman
was a talented neuroscientist from
Oxford and in 2029 her team put together
a number of previously unrelated
therapies including hormonal and
ceremonial imprinting techniques memory
enhancement the so called cure for hate
and gene therapy treatment and
old-fashioned conditioning and the
result with CCMS induction course a
course it was extremely reliable and
actually very safe simply undertaking
the induction course didn't guarantee
that a individual would actually
consummate so the CCM set up precisely
targeted real-world social networks to
provide essential human support during
the imprinting period and they learnt
from from the best
back during the rise of Christianity
2,000 years ago in the apostille the
gage Christianity first spreads through
hundreds and thousands of small tight
gatherings and the CCM copied that model
and accelerated it by multiple orders of
magnitude with the help of network
technologies early on dr. Otteman
identified Echo Boomers Millennials as
being particularly receptive to the CCM
these Echo Boomers born during the 80s
to the 2000s had a relentless belief in
self improvement to the Echo Boomers the
CCM of its self-improvement that
actually worked and even better
it required zero effort or risk many
people during the 30s and 40s already
took cognitive enhancers so they didn't
seem anything particularly bad or
anything wrong with this induction
course in fact it seemed much better
because it held out the promise of not
just making you think faster or
improving your memory but actually
leading you into joining a real
community of noble goals which is what
they all wanted and so here's a blog
post from dr. Waldman he wrote about why
people join the CCM she wrote we all
want the same things we want to help our
friends and family to love and be loved
to leave the world a better place we
want to be content and well we want to
be happy and prosperous because I'm
really too much to ask for
but it's hard it's really hard you pray
every day and every night but it can be
mighty tough to stick to the right path
it's a never-ending struggle against
temptation and against the darker demons
of the song some use meds or enhancers
or games to help them I don't object to
that
I think that's just fine but it'll only
worked for a while those demons and
those temptations will come back because
all you're doing is putting a bandaid on
the problem you're treating the symptoms
not the cure what if we could silence
those demons Oh what if we could use our
god-given knowledge and intelligence and
tools to improve ourselves that's what
he would want of us and that's what
we're doing here at the CCM now I bet a
lot of you played that Odyssey game that
came out that summer that's a part of
that way you
Odysseus have to tie yourself to a mast
so you wouldn't be drawn towards those
enchanting evil sirens when you did that
you didn't think that you were cheating
did you you were being smart because you
are confronting an evil that you
couldn't avoid when you can defeat on
your own it's just the same with the CCM
when we complete our course when we
consummate our lifelong journey our
souls have made towards Christ we truly
make ourselves into better people and
better able to help and love one another
and to love God you only need to look at
the members of our church to see the
truth of what I'm saying but you might
have to the card because they're not
proud people they're humble but every
day through their efforts through their
hard work they're helping the needy
they've rebuilding America they're
strengthening communities and they're
making the world a better place not
everyone believed what doctor Alderman
had to say other religious leaders of
course denounced the CCM as a cult and
it's induction courses brainwashing we
know about many many people who embarked
on the course of about having provided
fully informed consent a problem quite
characteristic of some other
twenty-first social networks
but there was an even more serious
objection if you remove the Smet of
temptation and the desire from human
experience can one still be virtuous
what does a even mean can one still be
considered to be human at all in reality
though the CCMS course of brain
chemistry alteration was not so powerful
as to remove all temptation from your
life but merely to shift them along a
more virtuous point within the human
spectrum taking the course did not make
one a saint although you could say it
made it easier to become one whether you
liked it or not so we're going to move a
little higher for the third object it's
a bit bigger
although friends say from 2039 although
friends say was one of the architectural
jewels of the 2030s who you all know
about it the space station represented
the flowering of space habitat design
and such was his influence on the way in
which we live and work in space that we
now talk about pre and post AF periods
the fact that although friend se remains
largely intact to this day is another
minor miracle one that saw it become a
soul heritage site in the twenty 70s but
I'm getting a little ahead of myself
although Forenza was conceived in the
late 2020s as a space habitat for
hundred people but unlike other space
hotels the station was designed to take
a step beyond the utilitarian style of
the late 20th century no ugly white
boxes and greebles were welcome here and
said the station incorporated a level of
elegance and fashion that saw fittings
and module fabrication directed by
experienced architects and engineers the
auto consortium began construction in
2032 taking advantage for
of cheap launch capacity produced by
fierce competition between SpaceX and
Siemens Foxconn six inflated inflatable
modules form the core of the station
heavily modified from ba 3704 plans each
module had a pressurized volume of 3,700
cubic meters and was capable of housing
25 people not only in comfort but also
in style it was furnished with lounges
sleeping pods bathrooms observation
areas and dedicated dining areas with
dedicated chefs designed by the noted
group of five by the time the main
assembly was completed four years later
though all Topher ensei is a regional
business plan which saw it become a
combination hotel and luxury resort and
become slightly outdated there were a
lot of hotels in construction at that
time 14 by this point with another 20
under construction and so the business
pound was looking a little bit shaky so
the consortium decided to change things
around a little bit keep two modules as
a hotel for tourists convert three
modules into a conference center and use
a final module is a first orbital art
gallery and museum two members of the
group of five shuttled up to the station
to personally oversee the installation
of their spectacular or wee chandelier
in the museum along with the detailed
fractal layering that enveloped the rest
of the station while the consortium's
decision struck people as being
dangerously optimistic about the state
of the world economy it's worth bearing
in mind that the semi-permanent orbital
population had now reached 5,000 by that
point and was growing rapidly although
friends say defied its critics flourish
does a popular meeting place hosting
exhibitions and zero-g art works and
conferences into the late 30s and early
2040 it's six
as a general-purpose high-end Station
three plenty of imitators the edx
campuses the famous Highline of Robinson
distributed venture complexes were all
assembled in the late 2040s along
similar lines to auto forensic but
everything passes the station which had
its heyday in 2030s and 2040s began to
snip from fashion late forties larger
more advanced more architect with the
adventurous habitats were being
constructed something captured asteroids
others from you an ejector even a
complete refurbishment couldn't save it
finally in 2050 one auto francais was
purchased by the Reynolds Mining
Corporation for use as a headquarters
and boosted to an l5 orbit in 2050 to
mere months before the cascade as such
author friend say is the only surviving
example of early 21st century low orbit
habitats arrests having been destroyed
deorbited or broken up for Salvage the
day the station has been preserved as a
museum in return to its original lower
Earth orbit though things with the
opulence of the auto events a station
almost feels like stepping back in time
to the high frontier this was back when
the hyper capitalists summer turned into
autumn and the first shoots of what was
to come next were budding all over the
world and off it
I want to do something different for
this next object I'm going to read you
an excerpt from a book called the
downvoted by Richard Cameron which was
published in 2045 when I first met Eric
both he and I were effectively homeless
one day after we received our guaranteed
income for that month
Eric took me out for lunch at the cheap
Bistro by Clapham Common in London I was
surprised by his generosity until I
realized that he was using me as cover
once again he'd managed to get himself
down voted on enough trust networks he
was being refused service this time even
the menus wouldn't actually work for him
his personal hygiene was hardly perfect
but I'd seen and smelt worse his clothes
weren't particularly old or dirty and
while he often had a surly attitude I'd
never actually seen it caused any
serious fights all of this is to say
that I couldn't really point to any
specific reason for why his being down
voted by passers-by it was a combination
of his overall demeanor and personality
that put people off understandably Eric
was frustrated by his predicament he
became grumpy and more antisocial which
only earned him more downvotes
like others I felt sympathetic towards
his plight but I was wary of being seen
with him too much for fear of receiving
down votes by association I don't see
you used to tell me you're completely
invisible I don't know whether it was
better or worse before these all four
contact lenses when people pretended you
just didn't exist now I'm told that
there are ways for people who are
literally put you out of their sight so
I've become this muddy shadow drifting
along the pavement and you know what
people will still down vote the shadow
the first time it happens you become
angry angry at the world who appointed
them judge and jury what gives them the
right to beat your verdict just like
that in a second what happens over and
over you just become sad and despair of
ever being seen by anyone again Eric
usually didn't like talking about this
and said he preferred to use the power
of his downvoted aura to magically push
crowds of pedestrians around the
pavement but today he seemed
particularly upset a liberal person
today on hearing the word discrimination
will naturally think of sexism or racism
or these days sent ISM both of which
have their devils and they're champions
they will not think of the low-level
murky discrimination that the downvoted
experience even though technically it's
equally illegal they will assume that
these problems ought to be impossible
thanks to our right to see and to remove
any personally identifying information
held on us by corporations and in theory
that's true but on the other hand our
society also holds sacrosanct the
individual's right to use private or
privately shared data to alter their
personal environmental virtual reality
this exception has meant that thousands
a private semi-legal peer-to-peer
downvote sharing networks have sprung a
button every city around the world
collected the identifying millions of
undesirables stamp out one network and
another will appear within hours or
minutes the only thing good about it
told Eric to me joking is that no one is
allowed to make a profit
it's all very cooperative providing that
we weren't out in public
I enjoyed Eric's company before a drug
overdose and a botched gene therapy
treatment left in the hospital for a
year there it could be a talented lawyer
after he recovered he found that you
concentrate anymore he bounced from job
to job eventually ended up in the pit of
the basic minimum income where he stayed
ever since
it could be worse he told me we could be
living in San Francisco I went on
holiday there once record of achievement
projects working at the Howard
Lighthouse kina streets I've ever seen
and that wasn't where any human sweepers
either they've got state-sponsored down
voting there citizen crowdsourcing of
antisocial individuals the law got
passed by a supermajority because it's
the ultimate magic wand a way to
identify all the creepy people and
criminals whoever and I'll be honest
with you he said that voting is usually
right sometimes the feedback to the down
vote is useful sometimes it's good to
know but maybe you side heavily at this
sometimes it's not so easy to change
yourself it becomes a spiral it's almost
like being exiled but without having
traveled anywhere besides Eric the
Streatham solidarity center house a few
other downvoted most of them had
discovered that their invisibility gave
them not just the means but also the
motive to commit petty crimes if society
is decided in the most dismissive and
also the most personal way possible that
you're worthless
then why not play along and really
justify those down votes occasionally
they would make sport of it saying who
could get the most down roots in a day
they use a funny old world event
gamification I think it was the last
time I saw Eric he told me when I asked
him about some possible solutions he
said he wasn't format wearing a mask or
a veil they're pointless your walk at
your smell the way you step across a
pavement they'll all give you away and
when they find out you're hiding
they'll get even more scared and you end
up with even more down votes
I can move away I suppose maybe the
London networks don't
as far as Scotland but it'll be a shame
because I grew up here
the micromort detector Buenos Aires 2032
every second of every day we're
confronted with choices that test our
appetite for risk she should you eat
that tasty but fattening doughnuts
should you walk to the shops or take the
car do you really want to take that
space dive it'll be fun but it might
actually be the trip of a lifetime
sometimes it's easier for us to make
that calculation the specialty of high
risk activities that have a very known
probability of death but most of the
time though we make decisions
unconsciously even though the cumulative
impact of all those decisions have more
weight on us living to an old age than
any single space dive but what if you
could measure and quantify of those
decisions immediately and directly what
if you could have a number that could
tell you exactly how risky an action was
going to be and that's what mutual
Assurance a co-op based in Buenos Aires
set out to make was their lifeline
bracelet in 2032 so this playset is
little old fashioned it just tracks the
usual things blood pressure oxygenation
level heart rate metabolic panel levels
galvanic skin response and so on it also
hooks into the wears glasses or lenses
to determine more or less what the user
is doing and how risky it is and all of
this health data and behavior data is
and combined into a single number
the micromort now the micromort it's a
real thing it was invented in the 19th
and 18th 20th century there's a unit of
risk representing a one-in-a-million
chance of death clinking a couple of
glasses of wine would accumulate a
single micromort we're spending an hour
canoeing would accumulate 10
microwatts taking a bite of burger might
give me 0.05 microwatts in theory a
lifeline would detect the entire sum of
its various activities every wash of
their hands every flight every run every
drink every kiss every human function
and calculate their associated risks in
real time reat reassurances aim was to
help individuals how their customers
make more informed choices about the
risks they took in everyday life and of
course to better assess insurance
premiums and make more money so
initially they plan to make the
bracelets available solely to their own
customers but the tremendous hubbub and
PR and marketing generated tremendous
demand and encouraged them to ramp up
production and know that much of the
appeal came from its novelty value
plenty of people enjoyed taking a drink
of coffee and seen their micromort count
and gradually ratchet up but a great
deal of interest came from how it played
upon the fears of the aging baby boomers
and Gen Xers of the time it didn't
escape the notice of the CEO there was
an entire generation that were very
anxious about their mortality and they
thought that they could address and
perhaps profit off that by quantifying
in a way that their users would
understand but the lifetime of course
didn't alleviate anxiety accentuated it
many where is obsessively checked their
micromort readings every how every
minute worrying over statistically
insignificant increases and becoming
paralyzed with indecision
sadly the heightened anxiety usually
increase their blood pressure and
cortisol levels further increasing their
microwatts of the day which increased
stress and so on but there are other
problems of the life line one was the
inaccuracy of the risk data rate of
relied on to make those calculations
most of the data have been calculated on
the population aggregate level basis and
so it's applicability to
specific individuals or circumstances
was quite limited another problem was
the inconvenient tendency for some
humans to be contrary some users
deliberately tried to increase their
microwatts as much as possible without
actually harming their health regularly
embarking on risky ventures and sports
activities just to get a high score a
few years on an attitude that shifted
people were tiring of such simplified
measures of their lives the fashion of
trying to precisely quantify everything
in the universe from health and
happiness to intelligence and
inspiration had its roots in the turn of
the century which was back when politics
and the economics of the time rewarded
people for thinking strictly numerical
terms believe it or not back then they
really did think that representing
things like happiness with a number out
of a hundred was not just a good idea
but the best idea the ideals of the self
quantification and the gamification
movements reaches as far as our 2030s
and then thankfully we treated as a
modern Romantic movement emerged
ultimately the Lifeline was never
particularly accurate nor useful as at
all for managing risk or improving
health but it did succeed however in
inspiring a new range of mostly
ridiculous occasionally
thought-provoking knockoff products that
purported to measure tiny incremental
amounts of change such as a microwave
fun detector their micro smarts detector
the microwave morals detect so and so on
and so that's perhaps the most useful
things that the Lifeline did those
trying to use it's simple metrics to
guide their behavior were frequently
stymied but that very effort and they're
very failure often prompted a fleeting
understanding of mortality and created
more subtle and long-lasting changes in
outlook it wasn't a magical device that
made people wiser it was more like a man
- Maury before I began the final story I
wanted to say a few words about the 94
objects that I won't cover tonight if
this is going to play along with me
that's a problem with this old
technology so some of the 94 objects
like babel and silent messaging the
Nautilus we in the brain bubble which
you saw at the start they addressed how
humanity became more connected with one
another during the 21st century but
physically and culturally but there were
others of course that saw humanity
fracturing away from each other
fragmented into thousands of communities
not the fourth great awakening in the
biomes and in the 21st century we
automated our economy with ucs deliver
BOTS with a mimic scripts the
negotiation agents destroying the entire
notion of work and employment these
words don't really have much meaning
today and we transformed our politics
with the constitutional blueprints not
satisfied with the trifling productivity
gains of cognitive enhancers and smart
drugs and glyphis we transformed
ourselves even further and even faster
with amplified teams the lace javelins
and that post-humans all demonstrating
how her burro sapiens became something
very different and not always in the way
that we intended and with our newfound
abilities we left our mark on streets
and buildings and oceans and mountains
all over earth and on the moon and on
Mars on a thousand asteroids all over
the system and even further beyond we
did what humans do we transform the
world around us and what will surely be
our most memorable feat we created new
forms of life the future remains as
murky as it's ever been
but we can be certain of one thing the
next century in the 22nd century it
won't be ours no be that's of our
creations and only if they understand
our achievements and our tragedies in
this most Swift two centuries can we
hope that they will improve the next and
it's on that note that I want to tell
you the final story of tonight it's
something that has just happened the
Armstrong expedition so eighty two
million four hundred and thirty two
thousand three hundred and thirty-four
extrasolar planets have been discovered
in more than twenty two systems 22
million systems in our galaxy most of
them are completely unremarkable 0.3
percent of those planets which is 2.8
million planets lie within the habitable
zone of their planet
of their stars neither too hot nor too
cold to sustain life of these 70 1349
are classified as highly habitable with
stable orbits moderate seasons and
suitable mass and these study of these
planets has consumed a great deal of
attention several methods exist to
determine whether conventional life life
like us is present on a planet one is to
look for short-lived biomarkers like
oxygen ozone methane nitrous oxide water
is also desirable but it's not a
guarantee of life now because a light
spectrum of a planet betrays a presence
of biomarkers they're quite easy detect
and we have found 589 planets with these
two biomarkers to date other strong
signs of life include oceans continents
seasonal changes and biomarker intensity
and changes on the planet's surface
the most direct way to find these
changes and find these planets is by
taking a picture of them this requires a
rather large instrument comprising at
least a hundred Network starshade
telescopes spread over a thousand
kilometers in 2075 there were 95 such
instruments and use and fifty-two of the
most promising extrasolar planets had
been imaged to a high resolution 24 of
which show clear evidence of
phytoplankton like organisms in the
ocean a further nine appeared to harbor
plant-like organisms spreading across
our continents waxing and waning with
the seasons the first discovery of alien
life was widely celebrated by humanity
when it happened
that is when ancient organisms were
found in our own solar system on Mars in
2028 further celebrations occurred 20
years later when extant life was
discovered on Europa by the time
extrasolar life was first imaged in 2055
celebrations were considerably smaller
the Wonder and excitement of life in the
universe being eroded by the slow drip
of discoveries by then everyone had just
assumed that life was out there
everywhere the planet were the most
advanced ecosystem grow 19b is a mere
328 light-years away making it close
enough to be imaged in real time by the
Newton array of arrays and a current
level of technology there are hard
limits on image resolution but experts
believe that the planet is home to
intelligent life and at least judging by
the settlement like shapes on its
landmasses
we think they're wrong and that's where
we are now I spoke to a researcher
recently from the Tsinghua chorus Berna
what caring about the extrasolar project
recently a few weeks ago he was visiting
the Cassini starshade away to discuss
that summers observations from Newton
and then during a break in the
conference he told me there was some
talk of sending a human crude ship to
grow 19b but of course it doesn't take
someone smart to work out that there's
just no way and you can push a human
rated biome even a tiny one for the
kinds of relativistic speeds that would
let humans get there in any reasonable
amount of time
artificial intelligence substrates so
they have some real advantages when it
comes to travel as far as I could tell
the scientists I talked to about this
project have the look of someone who
finally accepted some long-expected bad
news because the planet was due to enter
rapid phase of civilizational
development and next few millennia the
pattern of settlements the distribution
of resources on the planet that lack of
any obvious killer asteroids it was a
perfect condition for growth plenty of
people there would love to meet them and
talk to them maybe but it's not a trip
that any humans would be capable of
taking so a few weeks later went back to
the starshade advise on the newly
arrived armstrong expedition nano-scale
fabricators were swarming over the
improbably small and complex site hugger
spacecraft constructed on the same lines
as a shanghai the erickson to starships
sent out last year two different
extrasolar planets an antimatter fuel
source had already been delivered from
the inner system along with a new
posthuman designed saddle-point
propulsion unit soon a thick layer of
ice would be sprayed on to protect us
precious AI cargo from the rigors of
relativistic impacts there will be
another three months before the light
Huggle would set off there's already
attracting quite a crowd of
curious onlookers both digital and
physical one group was pressing for its
religious text to be inscribed on the
ice covering a delegation from Brooklyn
were hard at work composing some
classical hip-hop music to be played on
the ship's arrival but there was
something different about this
expedition a genuine first contact
another step towards becoming something
greater
except for this step humanity wouldn't
be present no one alive would be there
some commentators about the trip have
spoken about the idea of the great
filter about how awed it is that we
haven't detected any signals for
intelligent life from the universe from
our galaxy that something must be
stopping intelligent life from spreading
there's been a real mystery for some
time but here and now it's a plain to
anyone smart enough to see that anyone
who has a wit and the resources and the
means to spread replicators across a
galaxy and keep them there for a million
or billion years continuously
broadcasting a signal they just
understand the total futility of the
effort or the AI is I know would just
get bored too quickly but they seem
interested enough in this expedition
which is good news for everyone on earth
on Mars on Titan on Europa in 10000
biomes around the system humanity
continued talking living creating loving
and crying some of them knew about the
arms drawing expedition and perhaps a
few felt a little twinge of Envy that it
would go to a place they never could but
even though we can all our creations are
children they can and in this century I
think that's something that we can all
be proud of thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I sit up there this is pretty good
I've been around futurist for thirty
years and the first thing I really
delighted by here is that easiest way to
think about the futures dystopia because
it simplifies everything you tell a
simple story and what to see snowpiercer
the other night you know it's just
another there's a few people left
dealing with what's left of
civilizations failure and the other hand
you got the usual transhumanist
singularity story where everything just
gets insanely better and then disappears
on the other side of some kind of event
horizon and there's it's better out
there but we can't see it and both of
those were kind of giving up I think
about the civilizational continuity and
what we get from these museums and from
the histories looking back where it is
at each often at the times in history
people had those kinds of opinions that
that that there was a golden age that
was happening and everything would
become my absolutely perfect and or that
everything was falling apart and
everything was collapsing so in a way
what you're doing with the future is
what Looking Backward tells us is
actually the right way to think about
the future I'm curious what your
sequence of coming to undertaking this
exercise was where did you begin and how
did you wind up where you did well I I
grew up on a diet of you know Golden Age
science fiction the ones that sort of
talked about how the world was going to
be so glorious arthur c clarke and isaac
asimov and how men usually it was men
unfortunately of great intelligence and
rationality would transform the world
and make it a better place and so that
kind of is what led me into studying
neuroscience and and creating a games
company and doing the things that I did
and luckily I was around when
we my dad would bring back computers and
like a lot of people we had an Internet
we had Internet access just when I was
like 9 or 10 and so I was kind of sort
of roam free talking to all sorts of
strange people and and and that just
wouldn't happen now which is a shame and
because they didn't know how old it was
they assumed I was an adult I was like
you know 11 or 12 or 13 and so I was
able to have these great conversations
with people and I remember I had this I
got into this huge argument with someone
who thought that Noah's Ark you know was
actually real and we had this great
conversation about well how many animals
could you fit in there and how much food
would be needed and we kind of did these
calculations and I said yeah but
wouldn't you know obviously when they
all eat each other and and he said oh
yeah but like before Noah's Ark every
animal could eat plants I said okay fair
enough but I don't think we can really
have this conversation anymore and that
was just that was just a kind of a good
point I think it was like 13 or 14 where
I realized well there's a point where we
can't really talk about this but it also
meant that I didn't get into the habit
of kind of making fun of people who you
know had religious beliefs and so kind
of as I grew older even though I had
kind of funneled into science into kind
of computers and programming I started
to try to backfill my gaps in my
knowledge about history about arts and
about humanity and so that's kind of why
this future is inflected with the idea
of what's happened in the last thousand
ten thousand years so did you read the
the history of the world in 100 objects
and did that become the inspiration for
this actually that that was a direct
inspiration for this I mean if you
haven't if you haven't read it you
really should it's this fantastic book
I'll show you a little more what got you
umm well I thought it was really odd to
do a radio show about objects you know I
thought it would be better if they if
you could see of course originally a
radio show so all I can do is wave his
hands and say there's this alien hand
axe
it's about as big as your hand yeah but
it was just it was just amazing because
you know normally I don't know what it's
like in America but normally when we're
taught history in the UK it's just done
so quickly you know you've got we
stopped the Egyptians then you got the
Romans then you've got Henry the
eighth's then you've got the Civil War
then you've got blood war too lots of
stuff about Hitler and then history ends
there's nothing else there's not really
any objects when I think I remembered
looking through my history book and
thinking but that's stuff about China
here and the subway are we gonna cover
this and we didn't and so this this book
the this video show you know they tried
to go as wide as possible and after it
finished I remember thinking I really
want to find out what happens next
you know they got up to 2011 and I
thought I can't you know so what what's
the next object gonna be I mean and of
course this being the British Museum and
the BBC they didn't you know they that's
not their kind of style but um but I I
thought this would be a fantastic
project and so I I started a Kickstarter
which back then was kind of very cool
and trendy and offer back then are we
talking oh that was like that was three
years ago or four years ago and and like
all you know Kickstarter's it was you
know I project the late in delivering
but it was because it was just a lot
harder I mean it was a lot harder to
write than I had expected
was this the putting together these
stories was it you alone with your
imagination or given Kickstarter kind of
the crowdsourcing of the funding did you
do any crowdsourcing of the thinking you
know I didn't want to share the fun so I
just did it I just did it myself but you
know I think that a lot of the objects
did you put chunks of it out along the
way to sort of see what people did I did
I did yeah when I when I written about
thirty of them I started putting some of
them online just to see whether people
found it interesting or not
and I really wanted to try and you know
have it covers wider area of subjects as
possible because you know you talked
about how in other visions of the future
usually just dystopia utopia mm-hm I
thought like in the future we're still
going to have fashion we're still gonna
have religion we're still gonna have
cars and yes we'll have rocket ships and
so on and all of these things are just
as interesting is you know what kind of
iPhone we'll have but for me it's a lot
harder to write about cuz you know I'm
not I'm not an expert in most things
well it's just interesting because the
thing I got from when I started paying
attention to history is read a bunch of
history and in the sense that it felt
the same thing was invited to stop but
you want to go out and make some and
this book has the history of the world
100 objects has this other funny thing
of not only do you want to go to sort of
go out and make some history they'll be
make worthy objects that the can be
written about that way but it made you
become that kind of historian only
flipped into the future so a question
from Diane Tate is tell us about your
methodology how much your stories sort
of came out from research and how much
is just your imagination going batshit
you know most of these objects a lot of
them you know if you read the internet a
lot and you read blogs and you know the
idea for starship is not not new the
idea of desire modification some people
is not new did your neural and neuro
research and knowledge lead into some of
this I guess it did with the first one
that your show yeah it did I mean you
know my my newest science knowledge is
about 10 years out-of-date now which is
very sad but what really what what I do
understand about neuroscience is just
how incredibly quickly it's changing and
so that's why I wanted to highlight the
you know the capabilities you know if we
are going to be able to do some very
unusual things to our brains in the next
20 or 30 years and I don't think people
even realize even in
even what we read in the press even what
we see in movies is probably an
underestimate of what's possible and so
I wanted to talk about that a little bit
but with that with the kind of obvious
things the the obvious objects that that
you know have been talked about before
what I wanted to do was do a different
kind of spin and look at how just the
idea of contingency so with the you know
we're all very excited about you know
oculus virtual reality headsets and we
think it's gonna be great for games and
it's gonna be great for tourism and it's
gonna be great for sorts of things and
I'm very much looking forward to playing
around with virtual reality but of
course like any other tool it can be
used for terrible things and not just
torture or interrogation that
brainwashing and why why wouldn't people
do that we should just be thinking about
that are you the first to linked up via
oculus VR with brain scanning in
real-time to get some kind of feedback
capability that sounds pretty amazing I
would love to say that I suspect it's
you know now that I've been beating
around the subject I think that pretty
much everyone's already had the idea
before but I think that maybe using it
for law enforcement is perhaps a bit but
unusual to questions about the objects
and Kevin Kelly asks which of your
objects do you personally desire most in
cameo wood s which objects gave you the
most pleasure to explore and explain
they may be different yeah you know I
had a lot of fun I didn't mention once
you didn't talk about yeah I had a lot
of fun with but the ones that I'm a bit
more familiar with like the micromort
detector just because it's the sort of
thing that you're familiar with a
micromort detector it's just a sort of
thing that I can imagine someone making
and you know putting it on Kickstarter
when I met in Kevin Kelly being one of
the first customers were
in a way that it's something that you
know would be fun to use but probably
wouldn't work but but that's still
fascinating to look at because of these
you know it's fascinating to think about
failed technology just as much a
successful technology also what the
other question was I don't know what the
other question was was the one that I
wanted to have most once you had the
most fun figuring out and once you
personally really want to have the other
one that I really want to have and this
says a lot about me sadly in a bad way
is um this is I have I think one of the
big things that we're seeing at the
moment is just this idea of information
overload and of filters and you know I I
want to read more books it's not I don't
have a problem of finding good books
they're not expensive
but I just you know I read books on my
iPad because it's more convenient and
you know because it's connected to the
internet I'm just getting all these
notifications flying up and it's super
distracting and I could turn them off
but you know there might be something
really important happening so so I I had
this idea you know because people always
say oh I love going on planes I love
going train rides because I get so much
reading done but now that's internet
everywhere and we can't read anywhere
anymore so had this idea of um these
kind of specialized reading rooms and of
course this is you know you have them
and libraries you have them in you know
Oxford and Cambridge colleges you have
them in monasteries but the idea is this
was be something that you could go to
and there'll be different levels at
level one you you need to turn your you
put your device into airplane mode and
level two you'd sort of you know you
don't you don't have any other you're
kind of the hardware's locked to reading
and level three you'd actually be in a
separate physical room with a time lock
and a Faraday cage so there's really no
cheating you can't you can only like get
out every hour so it's obviously
inspired by by Neal Stephenson and them
and and it just kind of seems like well
I mean isn't that really pathetic so you
need that in order to read a book but
I think I mean we know that we want to
read more books I want to read more
books I know it's good for me
anybody here I read more person okay so
fix that problem yeah and and and that's
kind of and that's also informed just by
some of the I mean here we make this
game my company makes this game called
zombies run in it helps people run
faster by how many your view zombies run
it's pretty baiting and so there's like
a million people who run around the you
know away from zombies and the idea
there is we want you know the people
everyone kind of knows all of our
players know that they want to get
fitter but they find it hard to motivate
themselves to do that and so you know I
like the idea of making tools Act and
the users best interest and that helps
them mm-hmm and I think that we have a
lot of very powerful tools being
developed that do help people but they
also help the corporations that build
them and we are increasingly seeing
people understand belatedly is that the
interest may not be congruent except
there are no alternatives I mean you
know some of these things and natural
militant seem to be monopolies or
natural monopolies like Facebook and so
on and so that's that's a big project
than I'm kind of interested in but you
know zombies is a very small part of
that um a couple of questions about sort
of this scenarios in your mind as you're
doing these objects one from Michael M
how detailed are the scenarios behind
these objects for instance is the more
you can tell us about the group of five
who were associated also firenzi you
know a lot of these things come from
from I mean my idea for that was that
you know I I come from a gamer you know
at the moment I'm in a gaming background
I've noticed that some of the most
interesting games are being created by a
generation of grown up who are
multidisciplinary and not just
from skills they picked up later in life
but they are designer/developer
writer programmers and the idea behind
the group of five was that you would
have these these engineers who were kind
of artists competed designers you know
space habitat designers and that they
that's what they do and they sort of
approach it from a different direction I
couldn't tell you their names but like I
you know that that was and that it would
be a kind of tight circle rather than
the individual designer so that leads to
you can with Kelly's questionnaire your
100 objects part of sort of a unified
scenario in your mind of this of the
century so far being one story that
makes sense these little pieces of yes
it is meant to be 100 objects from the
same unified world which made it a
little difficult to be honest which came
first for you then sort of generating
the world and then sub-stories within it
or to the sub stories starting to go
here in a world that has coherence I
mean when I salted it because I have
very little confidence and my ability to
actually predict the future I I mean
there are some things that we can look
at and we have we have a we have a
higher degree of confidence in like
climate change like demographic trends
like changes in power of technology and
that sort of thing and so I can probably
say well look you know according to the
best projections we have there can be
more people up into a point and then
hopefully a population be leveling off
we know that climate change is going to
happen you know we know that these
different technologies are going to be
spreading out across the world and when
that happens things are going to get
things are going to change very quickly
and when things change very quickly what
kind of conflicts and what kind of
pressures will be generated and then
thinking about objects that would that
would represent those changes and
present people in that world is this an
accelerating world that you were you
were seeing and everybody talks about
tech acceleration and it's
they're if they're in biotech obviously
they're in computer tech and people have
been saying yeah but human nature does
not change that rapidly so it is some of
this kind of the collisions between
those pieces have changed between human
nature and the tech exactly I think that
I mean we're still you know we're not
Star Trek humans you know we're not you
know we still have emotions you know we
still are very irrational but I think
that the rapid pace of change not
necessarily of technology but just of
the tools I mean even if you froze the
difference between technology and tools
well I mean I guess to sort of be more
specific about that yeah I think even if
you didn't invent any more any faster
computers or any fast internet
connections and they different phones
we'd still be creating different kinds
of applications so if you throws
hardware the sorts of software and the
sorts of software tools I guess or
products that we'd have would still
continue you know it's moving the
hardware is moving so fast it's hard for
people to come of applications that
really even use even half of what our
phones are capable of and so you know
every day there's some new app every day
there's a new game every day you can
press a button and empty out your bank
account to someone halfway across the
world you know and that's a good thing
and that's a bad thing you know I I have
one of the objects which talks about
delegated buying power where you you
know most people probably don't care too
much you know what exactly what brand of
toothpaste or you know washing up powder
they use so the idea would be that you
might delegate your your buying power
your choices to a trusted third party
that could then exert political or
economic pressure on you know
corporations or governments or banks and
so you suddenly have the threat of bank
runs that don't just happen within a day
but they happen within a second because
you've delegated that would never happen
to flash crashes yeah so so that's
something that I kind of seek sometime I
think I guess scanning I mean you must
have scanned sort of fault with a
hundred objects and figure out which
ones you wanted to talk about in some
depth
tonight or some of the other ones that
he took seriously and then decided not
to do just because you couldn't go out
on life no we've got a little more time
tell us another object or two there was
one object that I wanted to talk about
the I mean the first object the first
subject was it was from was one of the
hardest ones to do because it had to be
totally believable but not completely
boring and and so this was the ankle
surveillance monitors and we would he
have you know ankle monitors for
criminals and you know the prisoners
yeah and and the idea was because of the
exploding prison population you know
this is something that is just costing
the u.s. in particular just a massive
amount of money and so perhaps we can
all save some money by going and then
people go outside and using these ankle
monitors but the idea of this was that
they would not just be streaming you
know GPS data they'd also be streaming
audio data both microphones because that
would be even better for making sure
they're not up to anything bad and and
they would also be streaming the
location of the criminals to public
certain types of third parties like
schools and police officers and health
officers and so it was this kind of
extreme example of well you know to what
extent are you going to be prepared to
sacrifice your liberty for safety so
that was the first object so a sort of
an enforced transparency quantify itself
or anybody can read the quants so just
to see that the prisoner is behaving
yeah
and what are you pretty cold but
somebody who's not a prisoner anymore
they're a loose but they're still part
of the prison system
I think information though all that yeah
yeah
I love objects that sounds great by the
way because a lot of the harm that
prisons caused is that you're in there
with nothing but other criminals yeah
you know the tricky thing is like I've
been sort of trying to put this you know
after you've kind of within the book and
it goes into village and you kind of
forget that you actually wrote it so as
I'm going to go and look up some of the
objects
this is terrible but but yeah another
object that because halfway through I
was writing the book I started out doing
getting that in a very kind of similar
style to nil McGregor's you know as a
kind of like very dry very professional
historian writing about the past and and
I realize that I couldn't it didn't
actually work for a lot of the stuff
that I wanted to do because when he goes
and says well this is an instance of the
first spear thrower right and this
amplified people's throwing power like
he knows that people know what an arm is
people know the spear is and people know
what of throwers
but if I go and start talking about
something in 2060 mmm you know with some
weird name and we don't know what it is
I have to go through this whole kind of
data dumping procedure about house you
know in 2050 blah blah blah happened and
no history will actually do that but if
you're writing for a contemporary
audience there are certain things you
know people are aware of and so it's
kind of halfway through I changed it so
that it would be more it would include
more found materials like letters like
brochures like questionnaires like
adverts and things like that and that
was just a lot more interesting to to
write about although also it kind of I
mean that the problem was it also sudden
made it a bit more disjointed so oh yeah
one of the one
one of the objects that I really enjoyed
writing about was um was negotiation
agents so and and also mimic scripts the
idea behind mimic scripts is you know I
I my company used to do a lot of work
for like advertising agencies and things
and they would always want you on
countless conference calls and video
conferencing calls and I'd be like
sitting there and I'd be you know doing
some other useful work in another window
and and they'd be kind of watching me
and I'm just be like yeah I know
listening and listening to what's going
on and you know because most of the time
there's like 50 people or 15 people on
these conference calls so I'm just I'm
not interested in what's going on I just
need to say yes at the right time and I
can just like and I thought well really
can't we like pass this you know can't
we use voice recognition and sort of run
this through something and just do some
very simple things like when Sean says
hey age when what do you think about
that it would just like ping me or go
and say oh yeah that sounds good right
and I would because you know this would
just be a great labor saving thing and
you know maybe at the start it would
just notify me when I need to go and say
something I would go flash up like
here's what was just said for context
and and you know you might want to say
this back but as it got better as I go
better you could just do it for me and I
could just go do my own thing right you
use it for awhile gradually realized oh
good you can leave the room exactly and
so and so you you know what happens when
you have like multiple people using
these things right nobody's in the room
exactly so that's kind of I mean making
decisions yeah and so because there's so
much value placed on your your you know
your presence within within these
meetings but like I mean that was kind
of fun one too right although I I kind
of more seriously looked at you know
there were some you know some people who
are kind of more on this sort of
autistic spectrum you know where or you
know have difficulty kind of reading
social cues and I thought well you know
could it be possible that that we can
have things that might better read
emotions and might be able to say look
at this person
here's something you might want to go
and say and so I mean and so I thought
you know there are really useful things
and I think there are I'm pretty sure
someone probably like an MIT Media Lab
they were always doing that sort of
thing probably is like making glasses
that will go and detect people's
emotions and will you know try and
provide support and it could you know it
doesn't need to be an AI or some
scripting that it could be just another
person you can have another person kind
of lighting along with you you know
looking through your eyes and just kind
of telling you what to do the guide in
your google glasses watching seeing the
same thing you're saying and telling
what's really going on yeah the javelin
yeah so the javelin is this was a story
about what the Olympics will look like
in 2048 so we had the Olympics recently
in 2012 in London and it was very
exciting and and in the UK and it's very
nice to see that a lot of people are
taking the Paralympics very very
seriously and of course there was a lot
of talk back then about you know should
Oscar Pistorius be be allowed to
participate in the hundred meters sprint
for you know in the Olympics not in the
Paralympics because he had these carbon
fiber blades and was it fair that the
you know he'd be allowed to gonna use
these because maybe they were kind of
biomechanically more efficient than
actual running and it turned out maybe
not but um and he didn't qualify anyway
so it wasn't a problem but it may be
thinking well look you know the these
sort of enhancements like the prosthetic
enhancements that are being invented and
developed now are getting extremely
advanced to the point where I think it
would probably be very safe to say them
within the next 10 or 20 years we can
have para Olympic athletes who will be
able to outrun or out jump or
out-compete you know any normal human
competitor and so you know will we be
seeing
better recrea no sort of more impressive
records being set in the Paralympics and
will that you know a lot of that
development a lot of that research will
probably come from technology companies
and for medical companies who are very
keen to show off the capabilities of
their new legs or their new you know
suits and so on and you know will the
Paralympics turn into Formula One
basically you know and like is that I
mean do we want that I don't know
it's exciting but it's also very
dangerous you know are you pushing
people to do things that you know are
very unsafe of course you know we have a
lot of sports so extremely dangerous and
we're perfectly happy you know as long
as people understand the risks we had
some of this with America's Cup here
recently yeah which was pushing the tech
completely and and we had her death yeah
because they were pushing it over the
edges and turned out that that's how you
find out where the edge is you're saying
that these personal sports could about
Drive so what's the javelin about well
the javelin is about that the object
affair is about the fact that in the
2048 Olympics and we the unusual thing
happens where a human javelin so
actually managed to out slow ordinary
human and also human baseline human
manages to all baseline human yeah that
managers are out slow the world record
from peddling beans and so people are
just just so amazed about this because
at that point the attitudes has flipped
over you know we used to be very kind of
condescending to to Paralympians before
so you know it's such triumph of human
spirit you know they try and you know I
think in the future you know it will be
look at these baseline humans you know
they don't have you know augmentations
they don't you know they try so hard
isn't it like impressive like how fast
they can run and so and of course in the
next Olympics is just it's all over and
his record is demolished by Python who
has just even more powerful you know
arms basically
so once again it's the story of John
Henry against the steam hammer and
there's a beat by giant hammer Eva John
Henry behind the scene who made the
steam hammer on it goes well it's gonna
be a great century maybe look forward to
it thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]